welcome back I'm Adam Maru it's time for
the PS Plus update for the extra and
premium tiers of PlayStation Plus my job
is simple to give you gameplay and a
quick overview of each game arriving to
the service while your job is to decide
what to play and throw a recommendation
in the comments below please let's do
this first up is near replicant or to
give it its full title near replicant
version
1.22474487139 as this is a remake of the
PS3 game from 2010. story wise it begins
quite simple as we play as a child whose
sister is infected with a strange
disease and we go off into the world to
find a cure on an epic adventure this
then builds into a hunt to track down
the shadow Lord the first eight hours of
near replicant are by far its slowest
and least rewarding especially the early
side quests but by sticking with it it
does pay off especially with the story
endings there are five endings to
uncover each with slightly branching
variations and one will totally delete
your game say waves you have been warned
it's brutal that it feeds into the story
perfectly gameplay Wise It's a blend of
hack and slash good old bullet hell
puzzle solving and customizing your
weapons and magic abilities to get the
edge neo-replicant version 1.224 I'm not
doing that again averages review scores
of 8 out of 10. next up is Sniper Ghost
Warrior contracts 2. a first person
shooter all about being an expert with a
long range tool contracts 2 most
definitely has great gameplay and also
some quite mediocre gameplay let me
explain the thrill here is to perfectly
plan and execute a contract by
stealthily taking up the perfect sniper
spot watching your targets for an
opening and judging wind speed and
velocity to perform the perfect hit it's
great but the moment your cover is blown
at sniper ghost warrior becomes a very
mid first person shooter with quite easy
to full AI the story takes about 12
hours to complete as you systematically
take down a crime syndicate and I
honestly believe your enjoyment will
totally depend on your play style and my
advice stealth stealth is the key let's
mix things up with an indie game
unpacking and yep its name is not a lie
it's a type of Zen game where we unpack
our belongings in a new home to find the
perfect spot for everything we slowly
learn about the person moving in through
their belongings going from childhood
toys to fully grown adult and the items
you may not expect them to Value running
at about 4 hours in playtime unpacking
is simple and surprisingly satisfying
and it's an extremely easy platinum
trophy too a game which will take
considerably longer to platinum is Sid
Meier's Civilization VI the turn-based
strategy game asks you to take over the
world by creating the greatest
civilization ever seen there is a crazy
level of depth to find with everything
from trade to religion to be managed and
how you run your government will impact
your cities then by the middle of a
typical game managing your armies
becomes pivotal as the AI controlled
opposition react differently to your
actions so a military is advisable back
in 2016 Sid Meier Civilization 6
received many nines and perfect tens by
reviewers and right now the PlayStation
version sits on 87 on Metacritic if you
like your management Sims less about war
and more about fun then Planet coaster
could be the game for you your job is to
Delight Crowd by building a thriving
roller coaster park with over 700 item
blueprints to choose from ranging from
simple bushes and rubbish bins to the
biggest roller coasters in history we
designed the layout and hire the staff
to keep the operation going managing
income and expenditure is the real
difficulty you must overcome then it's
only your imagination that's the
limitation the survival game for the
month is this war of mine as a group of
survivors hide inside war-torn buildings
as they manage their hunger and health
and must perform risky acts to stay
alive as a ceasefire is anxiously waited
for this was on PS plus a few years ago
if you're getting Deja Vu by the way
starting with four survivors each with
two abilities that can help the group
progress and it's the ultimate question
will you keep them alive Until the End
Jr G fans have a look at Star Ocean the
Divine Force originally released just
under a year ago we watch as a Sci-Fi
space Merchant named Raymond crashlands
on an unknown planet and teams up with
Leticia who needs help with her own woes
in return for helping Rey track down his
lost crewmates we then choose which one
of these characters to play as and from
time to time they split up and the only
way to know what the other person was
doing during these moments is to play
the game again combat is surprisingly
bespoke we choose what type of attack we
place on each button press so
effectively we're designing our own
combos which could be mapped to spamming
the square button if you wanted it to
another cool addition is blind siding by
staying out of an enemy's eyesight a hit
will cause them to be paralyzed for a
moment allowing your whole team to
attack I want to make sure I'm not
overselling this Star Ocean game as the
basic menus and HUD cause countless
issues and frustrations and ultimately
Metacritic says this is a 7 out of 10
game and wait there's another one our
ocean integrity and faithlessness
gameplay wise this is essentially the
same yet made quite a few years earlier
so the mechanics aren't as solid if you
can only play one definitely go for the
Divine Force like Divine Force this one
starts with another ship crash but this
time it's a young girl inside with an
unknown past do you fancy trying a
cyberpunk story based exploration game
this is cloud Punk we play as Rania on
her first night delivering Goods in this
Mega City this delivery job lets you
encounter the inhabitants of the world
and not everyone can be trusted
Metacritic says 64 out of 100 another
sci-fi Adventure on PS plus extra this
month is 13 Sentinels Aegis Rim a 2d
story Focus real-time tactical battler
we play as high school students who are
called into action to Pilot mechs
against giant monsters and robots about
one third of the way through this
25-hour game things change up so
massively that reviewers were asked not
to tell anyone to keep the stories a
surprise all I can say is time travel is
introduced and things get crazy Aegis
Rim has the same issues as Nia that the
opening third of the game is by far its
lowest and most cliched but stick to it
and you'll be rewarded back in 2020
Aegis Rim received a Metacritic score of
85 out of 100 and wait there's another
2D game this month Odin's fear low my
God how do you say that word Lee
Thrasher Odin's spear is based on Norse
mythology with many influences from Gods
like Odin and Thor with five
intertwining plots all set on the
backdrop of Warring kingdoms and the
approaching apocalypse Metacritic loves
this one 87 but the lowest rated game of
the month is Contra rogue car a run and
gun shooter that was universally hated
by critics IGN's 4 out of 10 is
particularly jarring so um let's let's
move on another indie game this month is
Tales Noir set in a dystopian Canada no
less where anthropomorphic creatures
live we follow a raccoon who is also a
private detective tasked with solving
the land's Mysteries if you've played
this can you leave a comment I want to
know it's worth my time for the sprungs
in your life there's another Paw Patrol
outing this month Paw Patrol the movie
Adventure City calls I'm certain it's
Game of the Year quality and finally
call of the sea is a first person
Adventure game set in the 1930s as Nora
here explores the South Pacific with her
husband Harry and Harry is voiced by
Marvel Spider-Man's actor I don't know
why I told you that it's a
well-respected game hitting 78 on the
critical scores or in fact there is one
more west of dead a twin stick
with a unique art style and speaking of
voice actors this one has Ron perlman's
Dorset tones if you're looking for a
fast-paced shooter reliant on your skill
and nothing else west of dead is that as
always what one hand giveth the other
hand taketh away the following games
will be leaving PS plus extra around the
19th of September so hurry if you
haven't finished these death Loop the
Groundhog Day first person shooter that
somehow received Perfect 10 out of 10
scores for is going replay the same day
over and over as you find a way to break
the loop Watch Dogs 1 and 2 are both
leaving the collection the open world
hacker and Espionage thrill Fest will be
gone next week and the jungle warfare
open world of Ghost Recon wildlands is
also on its way out too and say bye bye
to chicory a colorful Tale nidhog 2
through the darkest of times and death
and request too you will lose access to
all these games on the next update day
rip over to PS Plus premium and Deluxe
and the Star Ocean bombardment continues
with Star Ocean First depart which are
on PS4 Star Ocean till the end of time
on PS4 and Star Ocean the Last Hope
again on PS4 and around the whole month
off is Dragon's Crown Pro another 2D RPG
dragged up to date on the PS4 if you are
still here after all this time you have
my thanks I'm Adam you're awesome it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time